(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] For
some, life's simple.
- So what's your deal
man, what do you do?
- I'm a comedian.
(disc scratching)
- Aw, you hate to hear that.
- [Narrator] For
David, nothing's easy.
- It's like if I was 5%
funnier, I'd be a millionaire.
And if I was 30% less funny,
I'd be a multimillionaire.
- [Narrator] But when times are
hard, the laughs are harder.
- We're here protesting the
lack of diversity on campus.
There's too many
white males, like you.
- Jesus pal, you make me
look like Nat King Cole.
- You gotta pay your
taxes everybody, 1040.
- What had happened was, I
went into a coma in my 20s.
I mixed ambien with a
Terrence Malick movie.
- Wow, you must've
been in a dark place.
- I was.
A theater.
(whip cracking)
- [Narrator] See what's
got everyone talking.
- Fuck off.
- Fuck you.
- Are you fucking
kidding me man?
- No body wants to fuck you.
- Fuck off.
- This is a library.
- [Narrator] Starring
David Angelo.
- Is he dead?
- [Narrator] John Mulaney.
- This isn't exactly the
networking opportunity
I thought it would be.
- [Narrator] And
introducing Andrew Michaan?
So if fun is your thing,
- The late night parties,
the loud music, the wild sex?
I mean those are things I
report to the cops all the time.
- [Narrator] Come
along for the ride.
(shouts)
Tune in October 3rd.
- Well let me see if I
can clear my schedule.
- [Narrator] And we'll promise.
- I'd tell ya, nothing's ea--
- [Narrator] Nothin's Easy.